one of my favorite guests from back in
our podcast day he's not been here
before right now he is here with his
book why we don't suck and how all of us
need to be stop being such partisan
little what's the word that you used
right there [ __ ] Thank You Denis
Leary good to see you sir no you know
you're at the Rich Eisen show because
they're there I have never been at a at
a show yes where there's more framed
things with your picture or your name or
from your past I'm in the bathroom which
by the way I must say ladies and
gentlemen and I'm not kidding this is
the finest showbusiness bathroom I've
ever been in it's bigger than the first
apartment I had in New York it's pretty
big but like everything else around here
it's got framed rich eyes and items in
there one of them is a crossword puzzle
from New York Times which said 37 across
yes
ESPN's rich by the way the stupidest New
York Times clue of all time because the
ESPN's rich was there another rich at
ESPN during your than your tenth during
your tenure now not five letters long it
starts with the letter e and ends with
an F exactly so usually in New York
Times crossword puzzle which I've also
been in and not framed in my own
bathroom just wanted just want to point
out I've been in multiple times and not
framed it in the bathroom but I'm good
now now it's a challenge when my wife
goes why are you framing New York Times
crossword but rich I do blue eyes and
everyone in this bathroom and also your
clue is so easy I was just like that's
idiotic
what would your clue be I can't remember
I have I'm getting the Alzheimer's now
it's like well I do remember your clue
cuz it was only a few minutes ago it was
in the bathroom yeah well also you've
got your own bottle of rich highs and
whiskey in there yes some listeners
somebody said that to us from Kentucky
Bourbon yeah so you guys so this is what
he's gonna claim is that this is all
sent in and done by other people Oh hold
on a sec okay first of all let's let's
go one step at a time
that crossword puzzle was framed by my
own mother when this was back in like
1997 or 98 when I was okay start now I
apologize I'm trying to make you feel oh
no I feel bad now I feel bad no it's all
right but so I mean so here's my
question now yes that your mother God
love her yes okay and that's a touching
thing that she framed that that's I mean
I'm not joking now that's real
that your mother framed that that's a
big thing for a mom why is it in the
guest bathroom I would get Jewish guilt
eggs from Denny and hakeem olajuwon it
who else can see it that should be in
your house on a prominent display I'm
sorry right now but I apologize for your
son's behavior
oh my god that does bring us now to
number two on pretty much virtually
everything you see around here a lot of
it was my wife saying now that you have
a studio get all this yeah yeah I just
did that again myself and I think yeah
no I just moved again and my kids are
adults now my kids are 27 to 25 yeah so
he was in the last like five years that
they came out of college and and left
which is a how old are your kids now
nine six and four yeah so you're a ways
away from that but it's when the empty
nest happens you know you downsize I
mean the house that we had that we
brought him up and was too big and the
apartment without them and it was so you
downsize and you have to get rid of
stuff and the first stuff to go I don't
have to tell you is the sports stuff so
what went what's gone out of your house
it's not gone I've put it up in the
above the garage created a space because
I had fun I had so many some great
sports things melee Bobby Orr's you know
uh Stanley Cup winning goal signed by
Bobby Orr you've referring to me as his
friend I mean come on I mean that's late
at that point kill me you're not I mean
right I've got so many great things so
they're in the garage and I'm I'm moving
them into the gym but there's not enough
space in the gym so I may have to buy
another house that just just for me and
the sports stuff just a visit you know I
mean if you want we do have some space
on our walls would that be on you know I
would gladly give you a Denis Leary of
signed sports item if you take that
crossword puzzle thing out of that guest
room and take it to you that has to go
to your house doesn't it I don't know
what go I mean it's perfect here see
that's not a sports related item that is
a mother and son relationship item I'm
qualifying for your wife well speaking
as a huge sports fan she is you
so she should understand now she does
understand it she absolutely does but
there's some there is some stuff here
that that were would have no place in my
house I know some of the bigger items
like I've got a Tom Brady signed picture
and and I know that there's a Twilight
episode like like this in a couple of
horror movies so picture of Tom like you
know he sent a picture of himself
it's head and shoulders and he's on the
sidelines and he's he's looking very
intently at the camera right and it's a
it was it was a photograph but then it
was like painted right and it's signed
by Tom Brady now obviously that's worth
a lot of money anyways but that's not
why I have it what's he did he signed it
to you yeah excited to me right so I put
it up in the apartment and my wife after
a day goes take it down everywhere you
go in this room Tom Brady stares at you
and that's what I realized it's like one
of those horror movie things like you
walk over to get a sandwich at times
like don't eat that sandwich get avocado
you know it's like eyeballs are right on
you I'm like yeah we got a little creepy
time so they I mean they don't but they
feel like they did do it feels like he's
staring you like don't have that I
scream have avvocato I scream you know I
mean Denis Leary here on the Rich Eisen
show so in other words the the
photograph the pig painting looks like
the way he did on the side launch
yesterday by the way did I didn't see
his press conference did he say anything
about that what did he stood he would he
said he said can you say anything or
just I didn't see anything noteworthy
yeah I'm [ __ ] to say you're not gonna
get it so listen have you ever had the
opportunity to be on the sideline near
Tom Brady before a football game or
during a football game not thirty formal
game I was next to him at the media day
for Super Bowl he wants no part of any
pleasantness but for now he's obviously
very intense right it's like all great
athletes right so he's not like a Joe
Montana hey there's John cans right in
the stands guy you know it means so I
just when I watch they whenever I see
him going after Josh or anybody on the
sidelines I'm like that for me that
would be an easy decision whatever tom
says you know I mean you could see
McDaniels
kind of goes at it with him and then
turns his back to him sort of like um in
the same way that a catcher who has a
problem with the umpire yeah
always barks the prowl
towards the picture doesn't ya ever turn
around and enjoy I got stuff to do in
the headset that's not gonna play he's
like half the size of Tom we thought
he's looking up at him anyways I know
and then they're sitting there I was
talking about this with the guys whereas
we were watching it the network they're
sitting there but after they finally
calmed down the museum again they're
sitting there both on their yeah on
their tablets yeah who broke the silence
do you think I gotta think it was it
it's Tom it's gotta be Tom it was Tom I
think it was Tom I'm I get up we should
just get raw footage of that yeah and I
think it's probably still angry and it's
out of the side of the mouth I don't
know that's I've always said like the
NFL I say this about all sports if you
could make extra money guys like me and
you would pay extra money if there was a
channel like forget red zone network
that just has mics on all let's say just
the main players you have to have all
the players although I paid extra even
for the all the place right so that we
can hear it as it's going live so you
can watch like on whatever channel you
can watch the game and move around you
know be able to move around to the
sidelines whatever you want and find out
what's going on from never gonna happen
never happen never gonna know I mean you
a microphone even picked up Belichick
telling the the coach of the bills
McDermott
that the Gronk it was BS like he
actually said the word yeah her in that
crowd listen to when you that hit you
know and if your groc you know as soon
as he got up he's probably like I'll
forget the suspension the yelling from
Belichick after the game or after he
sees the footage is ten times worse than
the suspension stupid play and I like
crock meet your stupid eyes half your
size I mean come on I know you know it
but I how about the fact that none of
the bills wanted to fight him how does
it a fight not happen would you well you
got offensive end defensive lineman I
pushed them towards him that's what I
would dig guy should fight him right in
sort of like baseball fights to is just
like yeah where they'll don't get as
close as possible man run away from each
other but that one was like is some
nobody hit him one guy kind of pushed
him a little bit and then started
pointing to the ref
that was pretty sad denis leary is here
we're back in 60 seconds we'll talk a
little bit more sports and obviously
turn attention to your book why we don't
suck and while you wrote it eight four
four two Oh full rich number to dial
we're back in 60 seconds with dr. Denis
Leary here on the Rich Eisen show I got
the right side show Denis Leary is here
again his forgot about that
why we what did you forget about Brett
he was playing me yeah he was in the
booth with Lenny Clark back at o7 and
they're talking about Youkilis and then
they get into Mel Gibson it's fine well
no Gibson thing it happened the Red Sox
are doing the Jimmy punch area yeah and
we were doing rescue me and they asked
us to come and do the Jimmy Fund and
then stop in to talk to Remy and those
guys in the booth and you know that's
usually like you know that's like in
between pitches you put you they talk
about Jimmy fun and then you push the TV
show or whatever and then you know the
inning is over and you say goodbye well
that inning the Red Sox scored like 14
runs it was like a 30-minute inning
right that's so and we ended up those
guys ended up laughing so hard some of
the stuff that Lenny was saying that
they sort of fell out so Lenny and I
just had we realized oh my god we're
running the Red Sox booth right now yeah
so we went on I forget how we got on Mel
Gibson Oh because Curt Schilling is
pitching and Youkilis is faison's rant
had been and he made a great play to end
the inning and yeah take that we were in
there we were in that booth for like I
mean 45 minutes it was Austin you hear
about it when you got no they loved it
they loved it REM even those guys of
course some of the stuff we said they
they couldn't stop laughing but they
also they weren't gonna fight they were
okay with some stuff we said but
Donatello I just remember Lenny a night
at a certain point or holdin microphones
and Remy's on the ground over here
laughs and the other guys over here
laughing and we're like hey we're kind
of what's going on that's just like our
dream come true one of our dreams well
did you ever you ever want to be a
sportscaster you everything no I want it
to be I this is how smart I was I
thought I was gonna I grew up in
Massachusetts and I'm from Worcester
Massachusetts Bobby North America's Ito
the Bruins of that era one of the
greatest hockey teams of all time
hockey mad town hockey mad state so I
just never studied and that when they
gave me books in high school I would
just throw them away
because I was like I'm gonna be a hockey
player and and then I flunked off the JV
hockey team my freshman year you had to
have a c-minus average and I had I had a
d-minus average I imagine that and and
by the way the high but the coach was
one of the teachers and he's like I'm
gonna give you one great so yeah I was
an idiot but now what would you say to
those teachers I've written a book Wow
what would they think about that well
Wow all the nuns have thought there was
one not in particular sister Judith
Kaplan and I was I went to 12 years of
st. Peter's the same Catholic prison for
12 years with all the same kids in the
neighborhood all my brothers all my
cousins so the way it worked was you
know they if they hated your your
sibling or your your cousin in front of
you they hated you when you walked in
the door so as soon as I went in the
first grade they were like oh another
Larry I'm like oh boy so I just spent 12
years torturing them and this one nun
sister Judith Kaplan said to me I failed
the Spanish junior year in high school
and I took it senior and I just wasn't
even studying it I couldn't even say
like aqua you know what I mean like
nothing so she said I am gonna pass you
just to get you out of this building and
nothing is ever gonna come of you you
know why because you're an idiot and
you're gonna you're gonna regret this
and I'm like okay so how many years go
by a buddy of mine from that school
which is really incredible became a
Broadway actor and he was in Spamalot
which was sure one that he won the Tony
for that and it was a huge hit and one
night he's finishing before he's
upstairs taking his makeup off and one
of the assistants goes there's a couple
of old nuns coming up the stairs that
want to talk to you I was like Oh minds
why are they coming up the stairs and he
goes to the stairs to try to help him
and his sister Judith Kaplan had buck
teeth and he sees this all none with
buck teeth coming up the stairs he's
like oh my god sister Judith cabman so
they talked for like 45 minutes and at
the end of it she's like you're so great
and I
always even make something out of
yourself the Bobo she goes whatever
happens that Leary kid and to his credit
you guys nothing she could live that
dream oh my gosh I know he's in the book
she isn't I talked about her well
there's a sister Agnes Katherine that's
quoted on the back I told him back in
1974 who's going to hell this book just
confirms it yeah she hated me too hey
all hey why did you write this book I
wrote this book because the election you
know my previous book have been called
why we sigh we sucked right and this
time there in the election it got so
divisive and especially even afterwards
and I have a 25 year old 27 year old who
are emotionally affected by this
election and I you know listen I voted
for Hillary but I didn't want to I
thought she was a terrible candidate and
Trump was a hilarious candidate I wanted
to go back in and and I just write about
all these issues sexism and racism and
and sort of remind us how where the
common ground is but also kind of make
us all laugh again because all my
Republican friends weren't laughing they
were arguing with my Democratic friends
and vice versa they're all raged
tweeting at each other so I just wanted
to really make you laugh your ass off
again and you know basically forget
about the worst parts about it remember
with the things that that unites us yeah
we had sagging on a couple weeks ago he
said that he had the teeth takes it as a
responsibility to make people laugh
right now is the way he he called it
being less he did people get lost people
get lost you know I'm like I'm from the
George Carlin speaking of being Catholic
and the Richard Pryor school which is
that all politicians suck so to get tied
up emotionally into it with anybody is
dangerous territory anyways so this book
is anti all politicians just Pro us
because people did stop laughing even
some of my friends were comedians like
it's not funny anymore said it's pretty
funny it's pretty funny on a daily basis
so I just want it again
I hope it is oh so good I think the
people I'm hearing from her saying it is
making him laugh and that's what I
wanted to do Wow why we don't suck here
and how all of us need to stop being
such partisan little [ __ ] you said it
I did I thought you were gonna say well
I mean I I don't know I'm not you was a
bike you real I just say [ __ ] I guess
I just did I'll find out I'll find out
you can rich only say [ __ ] if it's in
the title of a book or a movie nobody
knows I think so I would say yes
probably you would say yes I'd say he's
only in the title you couldn't say like
croc was acting like a little [ __ ]
yesterday when he hit the guy yeah I
don't think that right would be
productive okay from my position but I
just said it well because also two
things I should have said that cuz now
garage kind of exceedingly cuz they well
and again in that we're kind of touching
onto something about how you're talking
about partisan yeah and the argument
right that it's kind of taken over the
sports conversation yeah but there are
some people who might call Bronk that I
would never do that because I've been
around athletes I know how he could lose
his mind I know why he lost his mind I
don't think he should have lost his mind
in that regard I'm more than happy to
have that nuanced conversation about
what happened I'm not just gonna come on
the air and call him that because if one
is I'd like to have an actual
conversation I have it to I'd also like
to have him on the show right and please
has you guys it very yeah
yeah has he been live in this chair yes
really
that's I know he wrote a book too oh wow
right he's busy told some stories and
someone else word process like crunk man
I think he's a great player but you
can't that's just and I'm sure he felt I
saw the apology last night that he did
on TV and he got mad in the middle of
the apology but you know again dude hit
somebody your own size you know that's
not when they're prone donnelly I'm not
when they're prone it's just stupid it's
stupid for the team and as a Patriots
fan its idiotic because now you're gonna
be at least two games I mean you got to
be suspended for at least two games and
it's funny how you said that he was
probably first things first wondering
about the hell he was going to catch
from the object because just the week
before he didn't he he basically said
that Belichick is treating celebrations
like Fight Club you're not allowed to
talk about it who died I think that
celebrations suck here's my thing they
gave these finally give these guys
freedom like create your own celebration
can you name one celebration this year
that you've got like oh wow that's
incredibly entertaining and really funny
not one in my book anybody the hopscotch
that the Chiefs did was pretty funny the
the duck-duck-goose was funny the like
c'mon I'm telling the Eagles bowling
last week was funny that the bowling
things been around for even bowlers the
bar is very low because these guys look
you know what the greatest celebration
of all time in football was Barry
Sanders no you do hand the ball back to
the ref speaking of Bobby Orr most of
the time when Bobby were scored in the
regular season he didn't even raise his
arms he went over to his teammates and
then went back to his position for the
faceoff I'm sick of it
did you see Belichick they was he was
wearing an NFL Films wire during the
Dolphins game yeah they showed him after
every Patriots touchdown he didn't even
move no doesn't even fist pump he'd even
smile
he didn't even listen the guy gives a
bead that he's a and you know you have
you interviewed Belichick yes yeah
because you know he is a really smart
funny guy yeah he's a really funny guy
but he's a remarkable mind and if listen
man I love it as a Patriots fan watching
as a football fan you gotta love the
approach but as a player you you got to
know like like that celebration last
week when when cooks when cooks jumped
on the crog's back as soon as he did I
was like you guys Belichick that's like
that's a twenty minute speech right
there is that the reason why the
Patriots aren't gonna win a Super Bowl
no I mean we just talked about sister
whatever her name is
can I just say there 30 years later you
still if you're groggy suspended for two
games that effect that directly affects
the offense and that the outcome of a
game and you got the Pittsburgh game
coming up all right so there there's
your answer I hate to be like Belichick
Gronk but you know like I have to sit me
and rich have to say it to Gronk you
know he's probably right now man he is
so bummed out right now why we don't see
some years are bleeding from the
Belichick screen I bet it is
are we done yeah well I mean you could
stay for one more segment if you want
yeah I do I come about when we
come back you want a John Merrow the
owner of the Giants has spoken correct
yes all right so we'll go over that
together okay
well break news oh good are you ready to
break news yeah I'm ready to break all
right okay Dennis slurry is here on the
Rich Eisen show we're gonna hit the Rich
Eisen show with Dennis Leary with Dennis
leering and all of his material that
he's going to put on our walls which
will be very odd and awkward that's
coming up here and I felt bad when you
said the thing about your mom that's so
we've got about a minute before the
recording you said you want to your this
this studio has inspired you so what
you're saying the studios I like the
studio yeah now of course my natural
jealousy and hatred have overcome my
friendship with you momentarily for me
to go like Rich Eisen has a really nice
do with a lot of people working for him
why don't I have my own talk show in my
own studio let's call your agent right
now very nice should we do that but no
how far do you live from here about 30
minutes not bad you down here we chat
yeah and you do like what four days a
week five five yeah in the studio five
days yes okay 15 hours a week during the
football season you're on the road I'm
on the road I'm yeah I mean I got I'm
working right this is pretty good won't
you be able to do it now the thing I
have to be in a network where I could
curse so I have to be Netflix right yeah
well that's a streaming search the as
you know yeah you want a guest host yes
but where I'm not here and you do huh
100% do it yes yes reality Hey look man
no I know listen Jon Stewart and and
Craig Ferguson the friends of mine talk
shows me I know like that is that's a
real this is a tough gig for ya and as
much as I love sports and I can talk
about sports like three hours four hours
a day man that's that's all that's heavy
work people don't realize how hard that
night so we'll find a gray area for you
if I could do like a sports related talk
show that was once a week where I could
curse hi welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show with Dennis Leary
it's hanging out for one more segment
here I've been talking about my pillow
for over a year now
we love my pillow it should be your
pillow do you need a pillow I just asked
you the way you're looking product I've
seen the guy on TV do have you use the
pillow of course is it good it is I know
what gone can I ask this question my
wife same thing really
yes so maybe I have to get my parents
okay really good merriest puts him in
his he's addicted to my pillows long we
have to try and let me tell you about
this deal if you don't mind go ahead hey
rich what's the deal on those my pillow
I'm glad you asked Denis Leary author of
why we don't suck my pillow calm by one
get one free tab take advantage of this
limited time offer use the promo code
rich at my pillow calm 10 year warranty
60-day money-back guarantee you get a my
pillow premium pillow you buy one you
get one free and and you rich if you buy
a copy of my book why we don't solve yes
and how all of us need to stop being
such partisan little [ __ ] you get a
free my pillow no you don't I just
fought we go very good
yeah it'll be great if he did the my
pillow I shoulda thought of it in
advance okay
so while we were while we were chatting
John Mara
yes co-owner of the of the Giants yes
president of the Giants spoke to the
media after firing Ben McAdoo in
longtime general manager Jerry Reese
today you're like doing sports talk
radio I know I am and then you in the
throat of a clip yeah here's John Mara
ladies and gentlemen after the firing of
McAdoo who had to go and the GM
situations plans that really had no
effect whatsoever to intends to
and obviously the public reaction to
that was not pleasant but that really
didn't have any effect of our decision
do you regret not intervening seem like
the plan to G knowing where that was not
right bang came up with the plan I
initially signed off on the plan my
hopes and my hope had been to talk to
him to try to have a little more
flexibility with and not have a hard
fast time when he was going to come out
of the game but by then you know he lied
there rightfully had rejected the notion
of only starting playing a half and
coming out and we had issued the
statement and it was just too late at
that point
in any event you know it is it where it
is and you ought to stop blaming Ben and
Jerry on that if you want to blame
anybody for that blame me because I I
certainly had the power to overrule and
if I wanted to I chose not to do it okay
wow that's pretty honest right there yes
pretty honest and let's be I'll be
honest yesterday when I saw the postgame
press conference with McAdoo where he
said you know as long as my key card is
working I'm a dude you shouldn't have
said key card soon as I heard key card I
knew it's not working tomorrow it's not
gonna work the more idiotic idiotic the
whole thing right whole thing you just
take an Eli out I'm no huge Eli Manning
fan and I'm not a Giants fan but that's
it's a Geno Smith I didn't even know
Geno Smith was still in the league I'm
being dead ass and I'm a huge football
fan I was like where'd they get Geno for
I know it's crazy a cup and the team
sucks you know this is coming for Brady
one day right you know this it comes
from everybody it comes for everybody
but I knew Mac could do was in trouble
when he starts licking the hair like
none of the stuff I talk about you can
bet on but I get feelings I when I saw
that guy the first time with the hair
slicked back I was like this guy's out
this is just it doesn't help the brain
obviously it's straining the brain with
the hair you know flattened out like
that but there was he just turned it can
I I know I can't say this word on TV
probably on your show well I probably
can't but okay what does it sound like
you want to do charades or what you want
to do it I can't just say it right he he
just when he started looking the hair
back and when he became the head coach
he
immediately became kind of begins with a
D and ends with Y you know dirty he's
filthy your thing is cuz you know you
said that you would definitely do a
sports talk show if it because I asked
you to fit you you said you'd like to
set up and whatever yeah and I said hey
you should do the show when I'm you know
when I'm out here or whatever although I
would always want you to do the show
where I'm here yeah
but you oughta - when are you not by the
way this Friday as a matter of fact and
who comes in the guest table well it's a
split between Andrew Cecilia or my wife
sometimes does it oh really yeah keep it
all in the family
that's very competitive though what do
you mean cuz if your wife comes in and
she's better than you oh god I'm not
worried about that because I hope she is
okay you looked at me thought oh my god
I just just I just disrespected my wife
no no I just thought like if your wife
comes out she's better than you people
hey rich no problem yeah but we do a a
segment called isin overtime
specifically for our app yeah you can
curse all you want on that okay I do
that as soon as we're done
okay ready the final poll results Chris
Brock I'll get it for me yeah the new
year's Bowl game you're most interested
in the Rose Bowl 40% 36% the Sugar Bowl
that's Alabama Clemson and 24% the
Cotton Bowl that's USC in Ohio and I
want to thank today's guest Steve
Mariucci Bruce Feldman Jerrod golf and
you sir Denis Leary author of special
thanks to me because I'm here that's
right and talking Denis Leary's book why
we don't suck tomorrow show Jim Belushi
and then Wednesday show Morgan Freeman
hey wait a minute Belushi gonna be here
live that's right that's the mine and
Freeman there oh man you coming back
that's pretty big the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience